Chimpanzees cannot speak human language because they don't have the vocal
structure needed to speak. But we do know that humans have taught apes to learn
American sign language, and in doing so they've been able to communicate with
humans. Researchers Alan and Beatrix Gardner for example, compiled more than
four hundred American sign language signs. That their three chimps have learned
to use through extensive training. Another animal, Kanzi, a bonobo, which is a
type of ape, understands at least 3,000 English words and uses symbols to
communicate with his teacher and other people. His teacher is Doctor Sue Savage
Rumbagh. When Kanzi was seven years old, they compared his language
comprehension to a two and a half year old human. Both of them had 660 spoken
requests to see whether they were able to understand and perform the requests.
And it turns out they're both able to perform the commands at about the same
rate. They were both about 70% successful. Moreover, what's really fascinating
is that one study showed that five chimpanzees who knew how to sign actually
communicated with each other for quite a bit. And when they analyzed their
signs, they found that 88% of their conversations were about social
interactions. These are things such as play and reassurance. The other 12
percent were about things such as grooming, talking to themselves, feeding,
disciplining, and even cleaning. That's pretty amazing. Another fascinating
discovery was about a chimpanzee named Washoe. She actually began teaching her
adopted son to sign. And only eight weeks after learning sign language from his
adopted mother, he began to sign regularly with humans. So how cool is this
stuff? I really love it. It makes me teaching my dog to bark when I say speak,
seems kind of mundane when these animals can learn actually how to communicate
using sign language. There's a lot of other studies like this. So we'll post
some links in the instructors notes box for you to check out if you're
interested in it. So the moral of the story is that yes, for some animals they
can learn to communicate using human language, however not at the level you and
I speak. So let's go to Susan to introduce our last area that we're going to
discuss about language.